this is the new front line we weren't
allowed on the covert ward
londonderry's ultimate elven hospital
gave us these pictures
they're battling the highest infection
rate in the uk and
ireland doctors say things are worse
than they were at this point in the
spring
where are we going to be if this keeps
happening we're going to be in
in great difficulties because you know
like as of today and i just come from
the ward
we are struggling to find beds for
people who are presenting to the
emergency department acutely unwell
with covert so this keeps happening more
and more of the
background non-covered services are
going to come under pressure
brexit hasn't put police checkpoints on
the northern ireland border
covert has with a high number of cases
in border counties like donegal and
derry
they're advising against all but
essential travel and calls for an all
island response are growing
this ferris doesn't understand or
recognize international borders
and we need to act together anytime
we've acted together it's been
almost accidental but the executive in
the north
the government in dublin need to be
doing the same thing and i
i think we're now in the territory where
we need to give people some hope
that we will have a christmas out of
this and that may mean a very strong
lockdown
for a few weeks listening college has
eight teachers out of action
either ill or self-isolating but the
head teacher fears numbers will go in
the wrong direction
if schools have to shut again we know
where the children are
we can trace we have tight protocols in
school
we can oversee that and i would just
worry that a circuit breaker might lead
these children to
essentially go out do their normal
socializing
and then the tracing absolutely falls
apart
the number of cases here is now doubling
every seven days
the number of hospital admissions
doubling every nine days
if they continue on that trajectory
hospitals like this one are just
two weeks away from having more patients
than they did during the first wave
the historic walls of this city provide
no defense against a modern invisible
enemy
streets are quiet business is struggling
but with covet 19
on the rise again northern ireland's
devolved government may have no option
but a short-term circuit-breaking
lockdown david blevins sky news
in derry